Masanga are we going to sakura on the
executive director of the luxor mankato
gamma institute from Sri Lanka I just
had a panel discussion whispering the
growth of South Asia and it was a
wonderful insight by all the panelists I
think for to spur the growth of South
Asia entrepreneurship is a mass and
social entrepreneurship philanthropy can
play a huge role I think grain the
ecosystem is ecosystem right and we need
a lot of courage within political
courage we need leaders to be courageous
in the addition making we need to get
the governance system right in South
Asia and also the country's regionally
need to play a role together to to
develop the economies